the Joe Rogan experience talk about
physical any day meditation right and
still meditation so as I say like
there's a meditation what you said sit
still and you just breathed and actually
wu-tang right someone give you a little
Wu Tang law
so what Aang the story is there's a monk
named Chang san-feng who leaves Shaolin
Temple because he feels that the
physical exercise is not the pure way to
enlightenment mmm right he thought that
the kung-fu was to external right too
many complications by ego and so he
retired so he retreats to the mountain
and he goes for internal kung fu but in
the process of doing internal kongfu
such as Tai Chi Tsing Yi BA kua right
like these techniques like this this is
they called the ACE peace brocade will
you just sit you know I mean and you
just do very small movements you first
you bang on the back of your is it's
called banking on the heavily drums to
open up the back of your brain like if
you do that right now if you clap make
sense if you cover your ears right if
you take the headphones off right and
you cover your ears like this you take
it down like that and you okay
of course it's louder right you hear
right oh it gives you a little rhythm
right so you do that first right and
that's just to open up your your brain
like to open that up right you do it
right inhale and exhale it bouncing
again and yang like that's one of the
blow case and it so you've made these
eight pieces of brocade right brocade
brocade means I got something is blocked
right
cade right so you want to open it up but
open up these open up your your main
vessels you know me okay course being
your ears your eyes your nose your mouth
you know that goes back to Jesus and the
seven churches what is the seven
churches that Jesus spoke to the seven
churches where he spoke to the two hours
the two loans two holes in your nose
your mouth you to it so he's speaking to
a man say out of his mouth came a
double-edged sword the sward of course
no so I can come out of your mouth your
tongue is that sword
double-edged exactly
so a wool shines all the preachers right
well anyway before the Conner league is
part of the compass so so we'll take
itself right
this guy leaves the temple goes to the
Maryland the meditate and he's dealing
with still meditation right but in all
reality when you mix it together wu-tang
in Shaolin you have the physical and the
steel meditation and it takes both to
actually find this level of
enlightenment you're looking for
so when Bodhidharma came the Shaolin he
actually came from India so Bodhidharma
was an Indian monk who was more of a
yoga student he comes to Shaolin and
he's trying to teach them the Indian Way
but he realized that all the monks are
too weak to sit there and they're still
meditation and so he created something
called the low hands right on the 18 low
hands or right and and he these forms
and these steps were made so that now
they could do a physical movement to
build their body up so now they can
meditate longer because you can have a
strong mind what's the use of a strong
mind without a strong body and what's
the use of a strong body without a
strong mind hmm so that's the yin and
yang must be balanced and so that's the
shaolin wudang philosophy so when we
made whoo tang clan and i'll go back to
myself with this we made whoo tang clan
as the name of our crew we took the
verse from the Bible about the SS water
Jesus speaking right we said okay we're
gonna use our words and our wisdom and
our spirituality to talk to the world
through our music right but we also took
that in the wu-tang law they said the
wu-tang mashallah monks they developed
the best sword style right so be like
well we're the wu-tang we have the best
sword style mmm but we come from Shaolin
because that's the the well with springs
forth way and so we took the physical of
Shaolin as our base the spiritual the
meditate force of wu-tang's and we
together and our album starts off if
what you say is true the Shaolin and the
wu-tang could be dangerous oh my god
that's that's hip-hop history ladies and
gentlemen
[Applause]